Work on these four assumptions.
They deal with the four parts of our nature.
For the body: assume you had a heart attack, now live accordingly.
For the heart: assume that everything you say about another person they can overhear,...
...now speak accordingly.
Always be loyal to the absent, if you want to retain the loyalty of those who are present.
Integrity means you live by the same set of principles in the totality of your life.
For the mind: assume the half-life of your profession is two years, now prepare accordingly.
As we move into this knowledge economy in great speed,...
...a constant need to invest in your education.
Experiences like this, online education,...
...getting back in the different training programs, school constant need for it.
And then for the spirit, assume you had a one-on-one communication...
...with your Creator, now live accordingly.
The cultivation of these four parts to our nature develops at its highest level,...
...what I call "vision for the mind."
"Vision" means you have the sense of what's out there,...
...you cannot see it, but you see it in your mind's eye.
You see the potential in another person.